in December 2019 UN officials in Somalia
declared an emergency and the reason was
right out of the Old Testament locusts
we don't call these emergencies lightly
you know we have to kind of make sure
it's going to be an emergency we can't
cry wolf you know it's really dangerous
but Somalia wasn't alone the emergency
declaration there also signified growing
trouble across East Africa and in areas
as far away as India despite increasing
equipment and monitoring efforts the
first wave destroyed thousands of
hectares of pasture and crops
nakooma is dr. vladimir cabeza dhaka
India to the rhodium but an extremely
welcoming discipline I mean yeah this
yamato-kun over 50 million people were
already facing crisis level food
insecurity right as another plague of
spreading we have therefore met the
assessment that Kovac 19 can be
characterized as a pandemic the covered
19 pandemic is far from over and another
massive wave of locusts is here
locust plagues destroy not only land but
livelihoods 20% of the land on earth as
well as one in ten people could be
impacted how is the pandemic affecting
what might soon become a plague and what
will finally put a stop to it first
let's start with the basics a locust is
a type of grasshopper only the type of
grasshopper that can fly 150 kilometres
that's three and a half marathons in a
single day while there are several
different species the one we're
concerned with here is the desert locust
or Justus circa Gregg area the name
refers to what occurs when their
environment gets too crowded their
physiology and behavior actually changes
they become gregarious and gregarious
locusts form swarms a typical desert
locust swarm can contain up to 150
million locusts per square kilometre
consuming the same amount of crops in
one day is 35,000 people swarms need
months of favourable conditions and
several successive breeding cycles to
happen in order to become plagues but
one plagues do happen they last for
years and require hundreds of millions
of dollars to bring under control desert
locust has one of the best datasets
around of any migratory pests in the
world because as it has the oldest
monitoring system examining that data
from 1900 onward plagues often had
lengthy cycles onsets followed by peaks
and declines that used to be the norm
but after 1960 recessions became the
norm
there were even stretches where no
swarms were recorded at all this was due
to improved monitoring and control
measures one reason for the current
crisis is that in some areas those
measures went unimplemented for far too
long if we go back to 2018 we'll find
the perfect storm
cyclones brought heavy rains to the
empty quarter of the southern Arabian
Peninsula which allowed three
generations of breeding to occur
undetected and uncontrolled sizes of
these areas are you know four or five
times in size of Germany so it's really
really hard also you've got conflict so
you can't monitor in areas that are
unsafe but there's another major factor
that's helping swarms to travel and
swell the biggest problem today is to
climate change
climate change is also complicating our
efforts to predict limiting the growth
and migration of desert locusts is much
harder this time around due to corona
this has dire consequences for many
already on the brink of food shortages
and that's because kovat prevents
farmers from offsetting crop losses by
doing manual labor in cities because of
curfews restricted movement and social
distancing mandates in short many now
have no other means of getting food
kovin measures also impact how locals
are trained to eradicate them you can't
do the traditional training anymore
really so you have to find kind of new
ways to do training at social distancing
and using video and you know Skype but
it's that very training particularly on
how to use pesticides that is the most
effective way to stop them some unusual
alternatives were considered until China
ultimately decided against sending ducks
to Pakistan to solve the problem and for
good reason traditional methods you know
like integrated pest management these
work fine in farmer's fields against
some sedentary pests you know seasonal
pests aren't migrating around but when
you have the migration component in a
pest that changes the narrative
completely in terms of control options
only chemical or biopesticides work the
chemicals are bad for people and the
environment in myriad ways and only one
company Novik rid makes the bio
pesticide which comes from a fungus
the Pakistan does have reason to fear
and the government has been busy
preparing the current swarms are hitting
the country from two different
directions and parts of India from three
control measures are essential but they
can only do so much until the weather
dries out and climate change is making
predicting that difficult desert locusts
also expand twenty fold each generation
looking at control operations in Africa
alone the locusts are multiplying much
faster than the pesticides can keep up
the relationship between locusts and
humans is one long continuous story and
unfortunately for us this particular
chapter doesn't appear to be ending
anytime soon